it's here important down government
scientists are
urgently investigating the threat of the
new variant of coronavirus
rampant across the southeast of the
country
in newly released minutes from the
government's own virus threat group
nerve tag
scientists warn this new variant could
ramp up the reproduction rate of the
virus
by up to 0.93
that could be devastating how did it get
here
what risk does it pose questions vexing
scientists everywhere it's not in a
virus interest to kill its host
dr julian tang has a theory back at the
beginning of the year
there's virus a circulating uh and this
has got the deletion mutation
lesion at position 69 and 70. uh and we
saw this deletion mutation around
in thailand and germany in january
february and then later at the same
later on we got virus b that's
circulating but there's no virus with
both of these mutations
combined right until later on
and then after august we started seeing
some viruses particularly in the uk
where virus a and virus b had combined
their mutations
into virus c and this virus is
circulating around the uk
with both of these mutations together
viruses what we have right now
the new variant in the uk
the government is so worried about this
fast spreading variant
that tough new tier 4 restrictions have
been imposed
to try and contain it but this is not
the first new strain of coronavirus
that has been identified this year in
other parts of the world
similar strains been in detection
denmark australia
and there are other variants that look
very similar to this
that have been detected in south africa
in the netherlands and other countries
we're not yet confirmed that those these
are the exact same as this variant
because this variant has a very clear
genetic makeup that we can follow
so how much do we know about this
variance
the existence of the new variant vui
20201201 was revealed
last week it contains 23
different genetic changes
in december it accounted for 62 percent
of all new infections in london
and is now becoming the dominant variant
in
the uk thousands of mutations of covid19
have been observed
since the disease first emerged
one variant called d614g
became a dominant strain because it
could spread more easily
a strain that originated in spanish farm
workers spread
rapidly through europe over the summer
and in november the danish government
culled millions of mink
after a variant called cluster 5 was
detected there
the concern for scientists is what
impact
this new variant will have and whether
it responds to the covid 19 vaccine
now being rolled across the uk
and this is the key question professor
robin shattuck
is leading research into the imperial
vaccine program so for influenza we're
very used to watching the virus
sequencing it seeing how it changes
over a year he told me vaccine
developers will need to study
this variant very carefully it's
certainly something that we need to
consider seriously at the moment there's
no evidence that it's
actually going to evade the response
that are induced by the current vaccines
but that may change that needs to be
monitored
so there's no reason for the public to
be panicked that it's going to escape
the current vaccines but vaccinologists
will be
looking and studying very carefully to
see if at any time
the virus does start to evade those
sorts of responses
viruses mutate change and adapt
now science knows it needs to do exactly
the same
joshie sky news